we get that little chunk of money we put
it deposited into these bank accounts
and we start pulling out cash
MH um and which works out fine because
we got a bunch of accounts and we're
pulling out little amounts 7,000 5,000
8,000 and you know I would cash checks
against her
accounts and they would call her to
verify uh there's someone here trying to
cash a check for $99,000 you know can
you verify the pay and they go oh yeah
that's Scott cugno oh okay thank you and
they cash the check you know these are
new accounts so it looks odd but you
know we're always I open the
account so what what ends up happening
is um we're cashing them and I remember
getting really frustrated because it
just taking
forever and I gone into a bank one
time and you know they have Banks where
that they they cash they actually
cash like large checks like if you go
into Bank of America and you try and
cash a check for $155,000 or 25,000 they
probably won't do it they'll tell you we
don't have that much cash on hand we
don't this we don't that they have
certain banks that do that so they told
me where one of those was I went there I
had a check for like
29,000 that had been cut on a closing
for Michael Shanahan remember I
refinanced Michael Shanahan's I've got a
check for 29,000 that was issued to
Scott
cugno so I'm sitting in the bank I go in
there I say I need to cash this and she
says um you're going to have to talk to
the manager I go okay she says go sit
down over there I go sit down in the
little glass cubicle he comes over and
he says uh I see you're trying to cash
this check and I was like right he goes
why don't you just deposit in your own
bank and I went my bank account my bank
is a credit union or something and it's
in like Florida like they'll hold this
thing for like two weeks like I need the
money now I have people I need to pay
he's like well um
I'm not sure and I was like well it's
fine it's a it's a cashier check like
it's good and he goes no it's it's good
it's good you have the money and he's
like yeah we have the money he said it's
just odd um hold on he goes back in the
back and he comes back and he says um
where'd you get the check cashier check
I said it was a cashier check it was
drawn off of a closing for um somebody's
property that I I were doing the company
I work for we putting on an addition on
okay that makes sense comes back why do
you need cash I was like I I'm cashing
guys checks that work for the company
like there's a lot of these guys that
are like Mexican guys they give them a
check they go to a check cashing company
or they get charged 5 10% so I cashed
them I'm like I don't under like what
the check's good right like my and he's
like yeah we're just trying to verify
some stuff any he went
um yeah hold on he leaves again and I
remember my cell phone rang and I pick
up the phone is Becky what are you doing
what's taking so long I go ah the guy's
being a jerk you don't want to give me
the money well she's like oh my God get
out of the bank get out of the bank and
I I can't get out of that bank the guy's
got my ID he's got my credit card my ID
and the check for 29,000 like he's going
to call the police if I just jump up and
run and I go don't don't call me again I
I'll let you know it'll be fine I hang
out the
phone she calls back same conversation
I'm I'm bouncing on the walls I'm like
I'm going crazy it'll be fine hang with
him he comes back out and he goes uh he
said um I said hey I said what's what's
taking so long and he goes um we're
trying to get in touch with uh with
Michael Shanahan to verify the
check it was not good for me like I'm
thinking right right okay okay and he
walks away the phone
rings Becky what's what's going on I go
he's there trying to get a hold of
Michael Shany and she oh my God oh my
God and I'm like Oh my and I remember
thinking I should I shouldn't left her
the keys there's a good chance I run out
of this place and she does she's not
there but by the way when you're sitting
there you're who Scott you're Scott I'm
Scott cugno and then the calling Michael
Shanahan right they're saying they're
trying to get in touch with Michael
Shanahan so then the phone rings my pH
cell Rings again I look and it's not
Becky's yeah not Becky so I pick up the
phone I go hello and she says hi this is
Kim is it from Sun Trust Bank is this
Michael
Shanahan so I'm like
yes it is Michael Shanahan and she says
there's a guy here he's trying to cash a
check it's very large could you verify
the pay and I go sure it's Scott cugno
he's trying I said I believe the amount
is $29,000 and she goes that's right
thank you very much I appreciate it I
said okay I said hey by the way how'd
you get my number this is my cell number
and she's like oh I'm sorry we called
the title
company and the title company gave us
your phone number well I closed those
loans that's my sale that's why if they
looked in any other way I would have
they could have gotten in touch with the
real Michael
Shanahan so I was like oh okay hang up
the phone you're sitting you answered
the phone from the bank while sitting in
the bank as as as Scott as Scott
pretending to be my so I right so I just
verified the check myself as Matthew
pretending to be Scott as pretending to
be M right yeah
so I wait there terrified still
they come out about 2 minutes later the
manager comes out plus a woman I'm
assuming maybe it was Kim she never said
anything and she walks out and she says
and and he counts out the money twice
29,000 29,000 and I st stand up and I I
mean just like I'm like shoving the
money in my pockets like I'm trying to
get out of there so quick I'm like hey
I'm like okay cool um like I'm thinking
this whole thing is life is you know
feels bad and I'm getting up and I'm so
I'm I'm starting to walk out of the bank
and he
goes he said um excuse me Mr cugno and I
said yes sir I turn around and he goes
I'd like you know like you to know that
I feel very apprehensive about this
transaction and I go really what is it
exactly he goes I I can't put my finger
on it and I go it'll come to you and I
turn around I just bolt right out of
there and so keep in mind a week or so
later the Secret Service shows up did
you cash a check for
$29,000 so um what's so funny is like
that was one of the last checks we
cashed so we ended up with like
400,000